météo toujours le temps doux avalanche
en série dans les halles hausse des prix
un mieux en novembre 0 7% fin du procès
de pékin la veuve de mao biome king
risque la peine capitale
mais messieurs bonsoir c'est un noël au
balcon que nous promet la météo il n'est
qu'à voir ce qui se passait aujourd'hui
sur la carte de france les températures
étaient des plus douces 6 degrés à lyon
pour la plus basse et 15 degrés à nice
pour la plus haute c'était vraiment un
record pour la saison demain même chose
nous disent les spécialistes nous juin
même les spécialistes temps doux sur
l'ensemble du pays vous le voyez quand
même couvert un petit peu partout avec
des pluies sporadiques essentiellement
sur les côtes de la manche et puis
quelques îlots de bonheur la provence
des régions méditerranéennes les alpes
nous dit on il manque un petit soleil et
les pyrénées mais ce temps doux en
montagne et vous le savez des plus
dangereux c'est lui qui favorise la
naissance d'avalanche hier nous vous
l'annoncions deux skieurs sont morts
près de la station des arcs en savoie et
bien un troisième est décédé aujourd'hui
des suites de ses blessures
et pourtant il s'agissait de skieurs
expérimentés mais il avait emprunté des
pistes non balisés des pistes interdit
est aussi pensons-nous qu'il est
indispensable de rappeler avec françois
cornet quelques conseils élémentaires
le redoux est trop souvent la prudence
sont à l'origine de la plupart des
accidents de montagne le ski sauvage
celui que l'on pratique hors des pistes
balisées de plus dangereux car il peut
déclencher l'avalanche même les
montagnards les plus chevronnés en sont
parfois victimes comme hier
effectivement près des arcs en savoie où
une plaque s'est détaché au passage
d'une équipe de 8 personnes comme
aujourd'hui à la foux d'allos ou un
pisteur a été blessé par une coulée de
neige
comme à tignes en fin d'après midi où
l'on craint que deux skieurs étaient
emportées par une avalanche
comme pour un exercice en montagne les
sauveteurs en rangs serrés aidés par les
chiens d'avalanche sont à nouveau la
neige cette année dans les alpes pour
retrouver les skieurs ensevelis
l'efficacité des secours et bien sûr
fonction de la rapidité de la leyre
malheureusement ce ski sauvage et le
plus souvent discret et les témoins peu
nombreux il est dangereux de pratiquer
même accompagnés par des professionnels
d'autres conseils de mise en condition
physique ceci avant les sports d'hiver
où l'eau n'arrive trop souvent rouillé
oumma lanta saison de sports d'hiver
s'ouvrent généralement cinq mois après
les vacances d'été qui sont l'occasion
pour beaucoup de dégripper les rouages
cependant il n'en reste pas moins vrai
qu'en douze semaines et parfois plus
on a largement le temps de se rouiller
notamment au niveau des articulations et
des muscles des jambes qui dans le ski
alpin sont le plus souvent sollicités
voici donnée par un professionnel du ski
quelques conseils qui vous éviteront les
courbatures après la première journée
je pense à trois exercices disons par
ordre de préférence
les mrc d'assouplissement la gymnastique
que l'on connaît les exercices
musculaires surtout au point de vue
des cuisses et muscles abdominaux et la
résistance de travail et la résistance
du souffle par des exercices de foot
voilà donc pour le ski alpin en ce qui
concerne le ski de fond les conditions
de préparation sont légèrement
différente car ce qui est le plus
sollicité c'est le système pneumo
vasculaire donc un entraînement
progressif ayant pour base le footing
est tout indiqué y compris pour les
personnes âgées dont le ski de fond est
souvent le premier contact avec le ski
tour
voilà donc pour ceux d'entre vous qui
profitent des vacances de noël pour se
rendre aux sports d'hiver
mais pour tous les autres cette avant
veille de noël et surtout l'occasion de
derniers l'achat et pour les
spécialistes c'est aussi la possibilité
de sentir le pouls de l'économie
ta moyens qui envoie un autre et qui
permet de déceler les comportements
d'achat en france un doublé ce qui cette
année a observé quelques modifications
significatives de gré ou de force
certains français doit faire un sort à
leurs dépens pour la majorité ce choix
va bien sûr dans le sens de l'économie
par exemple
plus question de laisser les fortunes
dans les restaurants le syndicat général
des restaurateurs à vous les prix trop
élevé du menu type de réveillon repas +
20 puce cotillons rebuter clients de 15
à 20 % de réservations en moins cette
année on choisira plutôt les menus à la
carte
il y aura du monde là où les prix seront
raisonnables ajoute le responsable
syndical des restaurateurs même tendance
au raisonnable pour les jouets les
chiffres d'affaires ont baissé en
moyenne de 20% et les commerçants se
plaignent
depuis le début du mois ça a été assez
difficile mais enfin depuis quelques
jours ça va nettement mieux un bon
chiffre d'affaires global est ce que
c'est mieux ou moins bien que la
dernière c'est plutôt moins bien c'est
beaucoup moins bien
tenue de réveillon difficile d'avoir un
chiffre d'affaires global pour les fêtes
là encore tendance à la sagesse boutique
des grands magasins vendent des tenues
dit
habillée mais que l'on pourra reporter
facilement toute occasion jupes aux
chemisiers pour les femmes accessoires
prochette noeud papillon pour les hommes
s'il est un domaine où les affaires
marchent bien cette fin d'année c'est
celui du tourisme des vacances peut être
au détriment de ce que nous venons de
voir les français de plus en plus
souvent choisi nos délais de tendance à
cette demande d'une part vers la neige
vers la neige qui a subi une très forte
augmentation de la demande également des
offres de séjour depuis quelques années
avec à la fois des propositions d'hôtels
et de résidences locatives qui sont très
recherchés par la clientèle
et on peut dire que qu'il s'agit de la
première de la deuxième semaine de noël
il y aura beaucoup de monde à la neige
cette année une deuxième demande se fait
vers les destinations que nous appelons
du soleil ces destinations du soleil
elles peuvent être très lointaine et on
note en particulier une très grande
demande sur les antilles et sur le
sénégal une tendance manifeste pour
l'ensemble de ses vacances c'est le
besoin des français de partir plus
souvent vacances même pour moi longtemps
même moins loin nous évoquions début de
ce reportage cette majorité de français
qui doit faire un choix dans ses
dépenses il y a encore de la clientèle
pour le luxe le ralentissement des
achats se fait surtout sentir pour les
produits de grande consommation
puisqu'on parle du luxe il est une
denrée qui sent bien la période des
fêtes c'est assurément la truffe à paris
nous n'y pensons qu'à ces moments là
mais dans le périgord
on y pense toujours surtout quand on a
quatre pattes vous voyez en ce moment un
concours très particulier dans le
périgord un concours de chiens truffiers
qui sont notés pour le nombre et la
qualité des truffes qui réussissent à
nous rapporter
alors est ce le signe d'une véritable
décélération dans la montée de la fin
des prix ou bien ne s'agit-il au
contraire que d'une rémission toute
provisoire
toujours est il que l'indicé des prix du
mois de novembre a fait des progrès il
est toujours en hausse mais de 0 7% le
mois dernier contre 1,1 pour cent en
octobre et services n'ont que très peu
augmenté et sont pour beaucoup à
l'origine de ce calme relatif en émaux
nourrissent s'en est félicité bien sûr
et il en a profité pour juger le
phénomène de la bad la baguette de pain
en chute libre la baguette qui elle a
atteint aujourd'hui un nouveau record
dans votre sens 80 centimes à
vendin-le-vieil près de lens pour le
ministre de l'économie reviendrait
perrin répréhensible sage il a
finalement dû mécanisme naturel de la
concurrence et des prix dont je crois
que nous sommes entrés dans une phase de
décélération des prix nous l'avions
annoncé il ya quelques mois je ne dis
pas que la décélération sera très rapide
mais est important qu'elle soit
régulière alors 07 c'est un bon indice
d'autant qu'il est influencé en novembre
par l'augmentation des prix pétroliers
qui ont eu lieu au mois d'octobre et qui
représente dans cet indice 0 1%
c'est un indice intéressant parce que
les différentes composantes les produits
alimentaires d'abord sont en baisse 0 8%
contre un à un les mois précédents les
produits manufacturés 09 dont 0/3
imputable au pétrole ce qui veut dire
que l'ensemble des autres produits avait
fait 0 6
enfin les services sont à 0 2 cette
analyse tout à fait étonnant pour les
services mais qui est influencée vous
bien le reconnaître aussi par une
actualisation
il ya eu une légère surévaluation des
honoraires médicaux en juillet l'insee a
fait la ratification au mois de novembre
mais dans l'ensemble 07 je considère que
c'est un bon
alors pour revenir plus précisément à se
prendre la baguette dont nous parlions
hier avec le fameux monsieur rodriguez
la cgt parle de dumping et condate on
melons et qui comme tous ses collègues
avaient participé à un conseil des
ministres avancé ce matin en raison de
noël il a confirmé la naissance d'un
établissement de crédit pour les pme
il a entériné les nominations des
présidents des sociétés nationales de
radio et télévision rien ne bouge
jacqueline baudrier demeure la tête de
radio france jean louis guillot à la
tête de tf1
maurice ulrich est toujours pdg
d'antenne 2 et claude contamine devait
faire trois leur nouveau mandat est de
trois ans autre nomination en conseil
celle d'une seconde femme recteurs
d'universités rowland gady elle était
jusqu'à leur professeur à l'université
de lyon iii elle sera désormais recteur
de l'académie de reims et plus conseil
des ministres a décidé que les mères de
famille de trois enfants et plus
bénéficieront de la filiation gratuite à
l'assurance vieillesse
jean-michel record les mères de famille
qui ne travaille pas ne sont pas
personnellement affiliées à l'assurance
vieillesse
elles n'y ont accès que par les
cotisations sociales de leur conjoint à
moins qu'elle n'y cotisent elle même
volontairement
si le mari vient à disparaître la mère
au foyer et exclues de l'assurance
vieillesse sauf si elles bénéficient de
la filiation gratuite jusqu'à présent
n'était affiliés gratuitement que les
mères de famille elles vont encore soit
un enfant de moins de 3 ans soit quatre
enfants et plus la décision prise ce
matin rétroactive à partir du 1er
janvier 80 étant le bénéfice de cette
affiliation gratuite aux mères de trois
enfants
cela concerne 550000 mères de familles
aux ressources limitées
au total c'est maintenant un million
huit cent mille femmes qui bénéficient
donc de la filiation gratuite à
l'assurance vieillesse
peu de temps après le conseil valéry
giscard d'estaing est parti en vacances
mais ça n'a pas été simple
l'avion réguliers qui devait transporter
aux antilles est bien parti mais il a
été obligé de faire demi tour en raison
d'un ennui technique un joint défectueux
dans le circuit du l'huile d'un réacteur
il a donc fallu que l'avion reviennent
sur orly après avoir largué au-dessus de
la forêt de fontainebleau les trois
quarts de son carburant il fallait
éviter que la paresse l'appareil materis
trop chargé ce qui se passe
habituellement en pareil cas le boeing
747 a été immobilisé pendant deux heures
il vient de repartir avec ses 3 187
passagers vers les antilles donc d'un
voyage que le président avait voulu sous
le signe de la simplicité
ils viennent le dire avant de repartir
toujours après le conseil le ministre
daniel hoeffel est allé inaugurait la
nouvelle autoroute angers nantes 64 km
il reste à construire
angers le mans 81 km la crise de
l'automobile
toutes les usines de peugeot sauf une
vont fermer leurs portes trois jours par
mois en janvier février et mars
peugeot qui cette année a perdu 250
millions de francs rappelé le socialiste
georges sarre d'antenne 2 min
le canard enchaîné condamné en appel
pour diffamation envers les cousins de
valéry giscard d'estaing à propos des
diamants que l'horaire offert bokassa
1er en forme et instances l'un d'entre
eux jacques giscard d'estaing avait été
débouté et puis la grève de la faim des
détenus corses à paris l'investissement
shell pollini et d'un état alarmant a
dit son avocat le miss à la justice
parle d'un état préoccupant mais le
problème est le même l'actualité à
l'étranger maintenant avec tout d'abord
la suite et sans doute la fin du procès
de la veuve de mao tsé toung
le procès pourrait s'achever demain et
pour patrick clément c'est pratiquement
fait chan chin sera condamné à mort le
dernier acte où l'avant-dernier acte
commence par la projection de photos de
tortures les torturer victimes de la
révolution culturelle
quel chantier
chongqing rogard la projection de
diapositives continue on y voit des
traces de brûlures et des traces de
coups de fouet
et des marques sur la nuque
tianjin gauche la tête elle garde le
silence
elle ne dénoncera personne surtout pas
note c'est tout ni même crois qu'aux
femmes elle nous ouvrir la bouche que
pour dire à ceux qui la jugent vous êtes
des traîtres
elle risque la mort
elle sait qu'elle a toute chance d'être
condamné condamnée à mort elle n'accepte
de parler que pour les insulter vous
n'êtes que des agents de tchang kaï chek
des agents du commune tanks des traîtres
l'une des juges s'acharnent sur elle
tchin tchin répond mais la voix est
brisé il est dur savoir que l'on va
mourir
même si on a été et si on se croit
encore l'impératrice de chine
un autre juge n'ose même pas lever la
tête pour lancer ces accusations
chongqing est seul isolé de tous
conscients d'être l'objet principal d'un
spectacle dont le dernier acteur la mort
chongqing le relâchera une dernière fois
où une avant dernière fois qu'ils sont
des traîtres des traîtres au noise elle
l'avait prouvé que la petite actrice de
shanghai savez descendre un escalier
elle a su aujourd'hui lors prouvé
qu'elle savait le monte avec derrière
elle dans son dos le regard d'un
milliard de chinois
je pense à cannes on l'a tous dit ce
n'est pas un procès un spectacle d'une
parodie de procès je crois c'est au fond
enfin d'ailleurs tout ce type de procès
suscite un terrible malaise parce que
dans un procès en partie dans un procès
politique
on aime qu'ils aient les bons et les
mauvais ou bien le héros qui luttent
contre ses oppresseurs symbolisée par
les juges ou bien au contraire la
crapule qui est jugé par la société mais
là où elle vient et où elle mal madame
mao tsé toung d'un côté sans doute elle
ne manque pas de panache dans sa défense
mais enfin il descendante sans doute
vrai que les crimes dont on l'accuse
elle les a commis l anr peut être aussi
commis dont on n'accuse pas parce qu'on
n'ose pas l'en accusé j'ai eu l'occasion
de voyager dans la chienlit chine
lorsque mme à la mode c'est tout mais
était la reine s'était effectivement
effrayant mais notre côté cette justice
c'est une parodie de justice
des accusés qui sont condamnés d'avancé
la presse déjà a dit qu'ils étaient
coupables avant même que le procès
commence des témoins à sens unique des
prévenus qu'ils ne peuvent pas prendre
la parole et lorsqu'ils apprennent on
l'a vu l'autre jour à la télévision
eh bien on leur ferme la bouche on les
expulse on veut d'abord et on veut
humilier et un public qui se comporte
non pas comme s'ils étaient dans un
procès mais comme s'ils étaient dans un
meeting
alors où sont les bons où sont les
mauvais en fait il est impossible qu'il
y ait dans ce cas là une justice serait
pourquoi mais c'est très simple parce
que les juges qui jugent ils jugeaient
déjà lorsque madame mao tsé toung était
au pouvoir
le président qui préside il préside est
déjà sûre lors de ma la mode c'est tout
même quand elle était au pouvoir
les témoins ou du moins certains des
témoins il était déjà témoin dans les
procès qu'on organisait sous le règne de
manama où tu sais tout et ce public qui
crie à la mort il criait déjà à la mort
au moment de la révolution culturelle
lorsque madame mao tsé toung était le co
tirant de la chine en ce sens ce procès
ressemble un peu à un autre procès celui
qui se déroule à bangui où l'on juge
également l'ex empereur bokassa sans
doute qui rompt singulière mais certains
de ceux qui le jugent jugeait déjà
lorsqu'il est l empereur que l'on sait
et cela me rappelle une anecdote vous
souvenez dans ce trou de chef avait
révélé les crimes de staline devant des
membres du parti communiste soviétique
absolument ahuri
tout à coup on leur disait eh bien voilà
l'homme que vous avez admiré voilà il a
tué des millions de gens voilà ce qu'il
a fait puis il ya eu 1 - silence quand
il avait terminé son fameux rapport
et puis tout à coup on lui a donné un
petit mot comme ça alors il l'a lu et
diarrhée marqué sur ce petit mot et vous
pendant que staline faisait tout cela
que disiez-vous alors il s'est retourné
vers la salle il a dix qui m'a envoyé ce
mot personne n'a levé le doigt et
khrouchtchev cela dit comme chef a dit
eh bien voilà ma réponse c'est
malheureusement aussi la réponse des
juges qui normalement ne devraient pas
avoir le droit moral de juger affaire
des otages en iran un diplomate suisse a
rencontré trois d'entre eux cet après
midi mais la suisse ne pourra pas
s'occuper de l'organisation du noël des
otages sains et plus tu étais en disait
ce matin qu on a envisagé par la
possibilité d'une libération avant le 21
janvier prochain date de l'investiture
officielle de ronald reagan
et puis le tchad avec une conférence de
les gosses nigeria très mouvementée
apprenant que hissène habré ne venait
pas à la réunion goukouni oueddei avait
décidé d'y aller mais voilà qu'il y à
une heure hissène habré est arrivé sans
qu'il soit invité alors essayons
maintenant de débrouiller les faux
tchadien avec tout d'abord un entretien
de l'émissaire du colonel kadhafi à
paris avec philippe est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire quand les troupes
libyennes se retireront du tchad
je crois qu'ils louent à 2014 les fat
les informations surprenantes de
l'envoyé spécial du clan kadhafi ne
peuvent pas masquer la réalité
la libye vient de remporter un succès
militaire décisif au tchad
le premier succès qu'a connu le colonel
kadhafi en afrique rend cette victoire
inquiète vivement non seulement la
france mais aussi les piles africains
limitrophes qui voit la première percée
vers le sud du colonel kadhafi et qui se
sentent aujourd'hui plus que jamais
menacée par la formidable puissance
militaire de la libye sa volonté de
conquête kadhafi l'a bâtie sur la
formidable machine militaire qu'il s'est
acheté à coup de pétrodollars
cinquante mille soldats 25000 blindés
300 avions de combat ultramodernes
de plus la libye dispose d'une légion
islamique portes de plusieurs milliers
d'hommes venus d'autres pays d'afrique
at sur le papier la libye constitue la
première puissance militaire en afrique
en 1980 plus de 500 millions de dollars
sont consacrés aux forces armées pour
les voisins de la libye
cette puissance militaire m'a qu'un seul
but étendre la domination de la
révolution islamique telle que la
conçoit mouammar kadhafi
la crainte de l'expansionnisme libyen
c'est un sentiment déjà ancien sur le
continent africain
dès son accession au pouvoir kadhafi a
rêvé de faire fuir des l'egypte et la
tunisie avec la libye les négociations
n'ont jamais abouti alors aujourd'hui
avec le coup de force au tchad c'est
vers le sud que la libye semble vouloir
déplacer sa zone d'influencé du coup les
pays de cette région sont la proie d'une
vive inquiétude
le niger par exemple ou encore le mali
le sénégal la centrafrique le cameroun
le nigeria chacun de ces pays
s'interroge sur les intentions de
kadhafi et se demande ce qui le fait
d'agir s'agit-il uniquement d'un rêve
politique ou n'y at il pas derrière les
grandes manoeuvres libyenne l'envi de
contrôle et demain les ressources
minières où puise l'occident on songe
bien sûr à l'uranium
c'est à dire à l'énergie de demain en
europe au niger cinquième pays
producteurs on traite 14 cents tonnes de
minerai par an en centrafrique les
réserves inexploitées à ce jour sont de
8000 tonnes au tchad des gisements
existerait précisément à la frontière
avec la libye
il y a aussi du fer de l'aluminium et
des diamants en afrique
de quoi stimuler bien des appétits est
ce que l'on peut appeler le kadhafisme
est un projet cohérent qui sur le
terrain a déjà des comptes aux précis
d'abord je pense au livre vert du
colonel kadhafi qui se propose comme
l'alternative la seule alternative
valable au marxisme et au capitalisme
alors selon vous le projet du colonel
kadhafi qu'elle est il exactement ce qui
vient de se passer au tchad pourrait
être bien le prélude à une vaste
opération de déstabilisation
ce n'est pas par hasard que qu'un
certain nombre de pays africains ont cru
devoir rendre leurs relations avec
tripoli
est-ce que vous pensez que le connais de
kadhafi est en mesure aujourd'hui
d'accélérer ce processus le calame dont
le colonel kadhafi peut le faire si un
certain nombre de puissances étrangères
l'afrique biais d' et je crois que ça se
fait déjà et qui peut empêcher le
colonel kadhafi de poursuivre son projet
les africains d'abord il faudrait que
s'affirme une volonté d'indépendance en
afrique
le refus de la domination étrangère
c'est donc dans un monde torturé et
comme d'habitude déchirait que le pape
jean paul ii a lancé aujourd'hui un
message de paix il recevait aujourd'hui
le prix nobel de la paix précisément
thème de cette année pour jean paul ii
pour servir la paix respecte la liberté
commentaire de philippe arbas
ce troisième message de jean paul ii sur
la paix est sans doute le plus politique
sont m pour servir la paix il faut
respecter la liberté
il est évident que les exemples ne
manquent pas où entre nations à
l'intérieur des nations au plan social
par exemple la liberté est blessé la
liberté de les céder le pape quand les
relations sont centrés sur le droit du
plus fort quand le bien commun et
confondu avec les intérêts d'un seul
parti qui s'identifient à l'état là le
pape fronce les sourcils du côté de
l'est
la liberté est blessé quand il ya
répression la liberté réduite quand des
hommes et des femmes n'ont pas la
garantie d'un emploi
mais jean paul 2 se veut aussi pleins
d'espérance il reconnaît que des hommes
des femmes des jeunes travaillent à
notre époque au service de la paix signe
encourageant mais limité la deuxième
partie du message et plus religieuse
être libre dès le pape sait choisir sa
dignité
or la dignité c'est dieu qui la donnent
donc la liberté religieuse est la base
des autres libertés
c'est ce que répète inlassablement jean
paul ii la liberté suppose le reçu de
souscrire à toute doctrine de suprématie
nationale ou culturelles dans ce message
dont on retrouve les deux traits
caractéristiques du discours de jean
paul ii sa préoccupation pour les droits
de l'homme et son désir de voir l'homme
trouvé ou retrouvé le chemin de dieu
les deux choses étant pour lui un
briquet dans un cas comme dans l'autre
il faut reconnaître qu'il ya beaucoup à
faire
oui un message qui pourrait s'adresser
en priorité à deux religions qui se
réclament du christ mais qui se déchire
en irlande du nord catholiques et
protestants pourtant aujourd'hui la
balle est signe de détente se
multiplient il est question maintenant
d'un projet de près les mêmes de
libération anticipée d'un certain nombre
de détenus de l'armée républicaine
irlandaise man is werther reviennent
belfast
quand on dit irlande du nord belfast on
pense elle sordide misère taudis des
taux catholique et ses frais du côté de
falls road chez les catholiques mais
aussi de schenkel chez les protestants
la pauvreté une saute aux yeux on pense
aussi aux manifestations aux attentes à
l'insécurité
c'était très veille une semaine lorsque
les terroristes
oui mon et certains n'est pas enrayée
mais en un petit problème de télé cinéma
visible en vous le voyez le son n'était
pas de la qualité de l'image
nous allons revoir ce petit film réalisé
donc par mois et ce werther en irlande
mais auparavant je vous aurais dit qu'
il ait eu un accident d'avion en arabie
saoudite une explosion dans l'ain
tristar qui a ouvert une brèche dans la
cabine des passagers deux enfants sont
tombés à la mer
les autres passagers 300 environ sont
indemnes
et puis en italie le verdict suprême
surprenant de la justice dans la sphère
du toto calcio c'est à dire des paris
qui on avait vu truqués dans le domaine
du football vient pas du tout dit la
justice faute de preuve suffisante ces
sommes ne sont pas coupables
ces sommes c'est lui dire par exemple
vous le voyez le guardian bertozzi et
surtout le célèbre paolo rossi tous deux
se congratule ils vont sans doute
pouvoir rejouer dans l'équipe nationale
italienne avant de revoir le film de mon
adversaire je propose un petit peu de
rêve un petit peu d'histoire à la veille
de noël
la langue est sûr parler de jouer mais
de jouets pour adultes plus précisément
d'automates très rare et très cher au
musée municipal de neuilly puis de paris
on peut admirer la plus riche collection
de france en la matière
lauren cusin a accompagné deux petits
enfants qui ont voulu découvrir ce monde
mystérieux
bien alors comme promis cette fois ci
nous allons musée puis peut-être après
en irlande est d'abord le musée des
automates les douanes
e
en vo
ou quand on fait des automates on a fait
d'abord pour faire des dieux parce que
les hommes ont besoin des dieux quand
ils ont des ennuis équipe elle l'aura
possible alors pourquoi volonté et après
ça on l'a fait dans un but philosophique
parce que l'homme a désiré faire des
zones plus perfectionné que ce que tu
avais fait alors on a essayé surtout au
xviiie siècle de faire des personnages
animés et perfectionné que l'homme plus
perfectionné que les humains du punk du
sentiment n'est pas levée des cas nick
mais ils ont pu tant que les zoulous
mais vu l'ampleur parce qu'il a
peut-être quelque chose dans l'oeil il
n'y a qu'un oeil gauche alors qu'il ya
peut-être un signe du ciel
ces bottes de leonard mayer en haussant
les épaules
un élève qui a passé des mois ou des
années à créer un objet comme celui là
l'iden peu à peu de ceux de son énergie
pas
mais malgré tous nos efforts n'ont pas
pu préparer le thé cinéma fautif donc
nous verrons pas ce sujet de maurice
vers terme et je pense que dès demain
soir prévoir ce sujet je vous rappelle
les prévisions de la météo dont nous
parlions tout début de ce journal une
météo vous voyez à ses douze quant aux
températures mais beaucoup de nuages et
parfois de la pluie sur tout le
territoire sauf les régions
méditerranéennes les alpes et pyrénées
ce soir 23h30 et avec l'aude
demain à 12h45 patrick lecocq que vous
retrouverez d'ailleurs à 20h nous nous
retrouverons en effet quand nous à 23
heures demain pour la veillée de noël
qui se déroulera depuis l'église
saint-etienne-du-mont se trouve à paris
je vous souhaite donc d'ores et déjà en
nous excusant pour ces petits incidents
techniques vous souhaite un joyeux noël
de bonnes fêtes
et puis allez prochaine bonsoir
bonsoir un départ en vacances
mouvementées pour le président de la
république monsieur giscard d'estaing
une partie de sa famille prenaient
l'avion aujourd'hui un avion de ligne
pour les antilles où ils doivent passer
une semaine de vacances l'avion a eu un
ennui technique une fuite dans un
réacteur
d'où un retour précipité à orly
quelques heures de retard avant un
nouveau départ et un bel et moi sur
l'aéroport où toutes les mesures de
sécurité avaient été mises en place à la
hâte pour l'atterrissage
finalement tout s'est bien passé chef de
l'état doit arriver en ce moment même à
fort de france
économie un mieux pour les prix la
hausse de novembre a été publiée par
l'insee aujourd'hui 0,7 pour cent de
hausse ce qui est nettement mieux que
les derniers mois les prix les plus
stables ont été ceux des services rené
monory le ministre de l'économie s'est
félicitée de ce résultat meilleur mais
en répondant aux questions de jean marc
il use
le ministre a aussi pris position sur la
guerre du pain pour monsieur monory les
pouvoirs publics ne doivent pas
intervenir dans cette affaire ils
doivent seulement veiller à ce que la
concurrence ne soit pas déloyale géré
aujourd'hui la liberté est en train de
produire ses effets c'est à dire
développer la concurrence et il va sans
dire que il n'est pas question de
retenir un seul instant sur cette
liberté d'ailleurs je ne crois pas du
tout que les boulangers et là deux modes
demande de revenir sur cette liberté
alors je crois qu'il faut être clair le
gouvernement est attentif à ce qui se
passe
il n'a qu il surveillera naturellement
que la concurrence soit loyale il faut
qu'elle soit loyale et on sanctionnera
aussi bien si le cas se présentait des
magasins qui achèteraient du pain pour
leur vendre moins cher qu'il aurait payé
de la même façon des boulangers qui
ferait pression sur leurs fournisseurs
pour ne pas fournir tel ou tel boulanger
qui vendrait moins cher
cela dit ne nous affolons pas les
artisans boulangers ne sont pas en péril
et que d'autre part le gouvernement vous
le savez attache la plus grande
importance à ce que représente les
artisans de quelque nature qu'il soit
boulanger lourde dans la société
économique française alors je crois que
c'est un débat qui prend une dimension
un peu trop grande je le crois au gré
les français à mon propre avis est que
finalement la concurrence est en route
bien on verra bien ce que ça a donné
le conseil des ministres avait lieu ce
matin en raison du départ du chef de
l'état donc à retenir de ce conseil
l'assurance vieillesse elle est étendue
aux mères de famille de trois enfants et
plus cela veut dire que les maires
pourront bénéficier d'une retraite
propres pour les années qu'elles ont
consacré à l'éducation de leurs enfants
le conseil encore défini la réforme du
troisième cycle des études médicales et
puis enfin il a mis en place le crédits
à l'équipement pour les pme la firme a
dû france elle continue de provoquer des
remous à saint-etienne les syndicats ont
protesté contre les événements récents
dans la firme stéphanoise est d'ailleurs
l'usiné toujours occupé par les salariés
pour la cfdt le pillage du patrimoine
stéphanois se poursuit la cgt a demandé
au gouvernement d'organiser
immédiatement une réunion enfin les
cadres de la cgc ont dit par la voix de
paul marchelli qu'ils avaient
l'intention de placer la faire sur le
terrain nous adaptons en correctionnelle
à propos des licenciements parce qu'ils
n'ont pas revêtu la forme convenable et
nous attaquons auprès du juge de référé
en ce qui concerne les dispositions
prises pour la location vente du
chasseur français et pour la location
vente de la vente par correspondance
car le comité d'entreprise qui existe
toujours n'a pas été consulté et il y a
là un délit d'entravé extrêmement graves
à l'étranger ronald reagan a nommé son
conseiller pour les affaires de sécurité
nationale il s'agit de richard allen un
homme de 44 ans qui avait déjà été
l'adjoint d'henry kissinger en chine
nouveaux incidents au procès de xian
shing c'était l'avant dernier acte de ce
procès la veuve de mao a de nouveau eu
des échanges très vifs avec ses juges il
semble maintenant très probable qu'elle
cela dernière acte où l'avant-dernier
acte commence par la projection de
photos de tortures
les torturer victimes de la révolution
culturelle
genting regard la projection de
diapositives continue on y voit des
traces de brûlures les traces de coups
de fouet
et des marques sur la nuque
changing hoche la tête elle garde le
silence
elle ne dénoncera personne surtout pas
l'autre c'est tout neeman crois qu phare
elle n'ouvrira la bouche que pour dire à
ceux qui la jugent vous êtes des
traîtres
elle risque la mort
elle sait qu'elle a toute chance d'être
condamné condamnée à mort elle n'accepte
de parler que pour les insulter vous
n'êtes que des agents de tchang kaï chek
les agents du commune tente d'être être
l'une des juges s'acharnent sur elle
tchin tchin répond mais la voix est
brisé il est dur savoir que l'on va
mourir
même si on a été et si on se croit
encore la piraterie de chiens en afrique
la conférence de lagos sur le tchad
s'est ouverte ce matin elle a pris une
tournure inattendue en effet goukouni
oueddei l'homme fort du tchad est arrivé
aujourd'hui à lagos alors que l'on
attendait pas il n'est pas certain
toutefois qu'il participe aux travaux de
cette conférence
voilà donc les informations
internationales principal de cette
journée du 23 décembre
nous approchons de la fin de l'année et
les bons d'en faire un bilan à travers
les faits majeurs qui ont marqué 1980
les faits majeurs c'est-à-dire
l'invasion de l'afghanistan
les remous en pologne les otages de
téhéran et l'élection de ronald reagan
la chronique de paul nahon finalement
sept années 1980 s'achève un petit peu
mieux qu'elle n'avait débuté
rappelez vous il y a un an c'était
l'invasion de l'afghanistan par les
troupes soviétiques et la menace de
conflit généralisé à la suite de ce coup
de force
c'est donc la sagesse qui a prévalu même
si les menaces ont toujours aussi
présente la plus grave reste encore la
pologne avec son épée de damoclès à
savoir l'intervention des troupes du
pacte de varsovie au cas où la légalité
socialiste ne serait plus respectées en
pologne d'ailleurs les syndicats le
gouvernement continue de marcher sur le
fil du rasoir avec en toile de fond une
situation économique tellement
catastrophique qu'elle pourrait servir
de détonateur ou de prétexte à une
intervention étrangère
presque comme l'afghanistan les
occidentaux n'iront pas déclencher une
guerre
pour la pologne mais pour l'instant le
kremlin les pays du tiers monde
l'amérique latine et les européens
attendent avec une certaine impatience
disons la première décision du nouveau
président des états unis dont je crois
l'élection a sans doute été le véritable
évènement de cette année 1980 on connaît
désormais la composition du gouvernement
de monsieur reggane gouvernement musclée
dont les intentions de laisse aucun
doute sur l'attitude à avoir vis-à-vis
de l'union soviétique
ronald reagan sera très vite d'ailleurs
confronté un premier problème est tout à
fait concret lui à savoir les otages
américains qui s'apprêtent à passer leur
deuxième noël en captivité à téhéran et
l'emploi de la force vous savez a été le
thème dominant de la campagne du nouveau
président mais il ya souvent
heureusement l'occurrence dans ce cas
précis un décalage important entre les
promesses d'un candidat et ses actes
arrivé à la magistrature suprême
en bref encore la phase 1 de john lennon
a été inculpé aujourd'hui de meurtre
sans préméditation
mark chapman risque une peine de 25 ans
de prison
attention aux avalanches en montagne en
france au moins le redoux provoque des
avalanches particulièrement dans les
alpes
hier aux harkis lee a finalement eu
trois morts aujourd'hui des avalanches à
tignes et à la foux d'allos ont blessé
plusieurs skieurs puis pour terminer sur
une note plus optimiste et bien cette
information sympathique qui vient des
états unis précisément de phoenix dans
l'arizona
là bas comme partout si l'on fait une
faute de conduite on attrape une
contravention
par contre si l'on conduit bien on a des
bons points quand un automobiliste de
phoenix fait une bonne action si par
exemple il ne s'impatiente pas derrière
une voiture trop lente ou bien s'il
respecte bien les priorités il peut se
faire arrêter par les policiers
mais alors les policiers lui remettent
un chèque de 15 $ l'expérience est due à
une compagnie d'assurances qui
semble-t-il il trouve tout à fait son
compte
ce soir le livre nous sert à découvrir
un autre art la peinture avec un très
beau livre des traînes que présente
georges b ce livre est consacré un
peintre de la fin du xvème siècle et du
début du xvième joaquin pas tenir en
fait vous allez le voir
cette artiste était un véritable
précurseur georges des coûts si vous ne
connaissez pas le peintre joan sympathie
ni je vous invite à vous procurer très
vite ce livre paru chez laffont pas
tenir ou l'harmonie du monde par maurice
pons et andré barret patine irene à la
fin du xvème siècle à l'époque où clé
sauf que l'on croyait découvrir les
indes autant que l'on croyait encore que
la terre était plate
contemporain de durèrent qui nous laisse
à ce portrait de pas tenir ce
surréaliste avant la lettre exerça ses
talents à bruges puis à anvers comme
beaucoup de peintres de l'époque sa
clientèle est en noble ou religieuse il
s'attacha à peindre les paraboles de
l'histoire 5
il n'y a rien là d'original mais le
génie de patiner vous le constatez et
d'avoir peuple et les rives de la meuse
de rochers cristallin semblables à ceux
du colorado
sans quitter son atelier il fait un tour
du monde imaginaire il invente il fait
surgir de la terre ardennaise les
paysages d'une nouvelle planète
regardez n'est ce pas un ovni dans un
verger doute n'est-il ces informations
jouets sympathie ni qu'en pensez vous
dali magritte et quirico ont dû
s'extasier devant ses toiles vieille de
cinq siècles n'en est-il rien rester
dans leur mémoire de peintre
pour un bain d'harmonie pour la
découverte d'un personnage secret et
pour vous éviter de faire le tour des
musées de rotterdam à madrid
je vous conseille ce livre d'art il vaut
son pesant de rêve
voilà et bien avant de rêver
complètement être dormir un mot de la
météo pour demain et bien le temps ne va
pas beaucoup changé par rapport au jour
d'hui vous le voyez sur la carte il y
aura encore du soleil sur le sud c'est à
dire sur les pyrénées les régions
méditerranéennes et les alpes là il fera
beau donc sur les autres régions c'est à
dire plus au nord le temps sera doux et
nuageux avec des petites pluies éparses
ces pluies s'intensifieront en soirée
sur les régions voisines de la manche et
le temps se refroidira un petit peu pour
la fin du journal merci d'être resté
avec nous si tard je vous souhaite
maintenant de passer donc une excellente
nuit
le prochain rendez vous avec
l'information cette antenne de midi
comme chaque jour à 12h45 bonsoir